[Musique]
salut a tous aussi sexy de lanceurs
animateur de l'émission les décrypteurs
oui on est en pleine pandémie de kobe de
19 mais aussi en pleine info démis le
terme existent et employés même par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé il
ya énormément d information en ce moment
sur le web ce qui accentue la crise
sanitaire actuelle alors annoncé
quelques trucs en rafale pour que vous
puissiez faire votre part dans ce combat
contre la désinformation basé sur la
coved 19
d'abord si une information qui vous
apparaît douteuses sur laquelle vous
avez des questions vérifier si ce radio
canada.ca on aborder cet élément
d'information vous pouvez aussi vous
rendre sur radio canada.ca barres
obliques décrypteurs jay fier de bouchra
wathiq votre humble serviteur et notre
collègue mathieu gobeil
on travaille d'arrache-pied pour
continuer à départager le vrai du faux
dans ce contexte de pandémie autre
marche à suivre importante comparé les
éléments qui vous paraissent lochou sur
lesquels vous avez des questions avec ce
que publient les agences de santé
publique que ce soit l'om est ce à
l'échelle planétaire où l' agence
canadienne de santé publique ou les
agences de santé publique dans les
provinces pour trouver parce que elle
aussi ces agences font leurs efforts
contre la désinformation du conduit très
précis et très complet citron un
troisième élément à retenir la fiabilité
des sites web sur lesquels vous trouvez
un petit coup d'oeil suffit sur la barre
de navigation pour se rendre compte
parfois contrat fait les adresses réel
de sites web réel fiam pour d'autres
adresses
aussi il ya des extensions que vous
pouvez ajouter à votre barre de
navigation que ce soit news corp ou
encore des codex du quotidien le monde
qui vous indique si un site web et
fiable ou non et finalement si en bout
de ligne vous n'arrivez pas à contre
vérifier une information
écrivez nous à notre adresse courriel
celle des décrypteurs adhérer à notre
groupe facebook celui des décrypteurs et
dans la mesure du possible le plus
rapidement possible on va tenter de vous
répondre et dissiper le doute dans votre
esprit
allez salut et prenez soin de vous